we begin tonight with the battle online
to tell the truth about the pandemic
today youtube announced that it is
shutting down several high-profile
accounts as it cracks down on covid 19
misinformation and anti-vaccine
conspiracy theories the u.s based
company banned the popular accounts of
robert f kennedy jr and joseph mercola
for spreading false information about
vaccines in a similar move it took down
both german language channels of russian
state broadcaster rt formerly known as
russia today without disclosing which of
rt's videos broke its rules
our digital reporter pablo foley elias
is following this story for us
how did rt's german youtube channel end
up being deleted right well youtube
which is owned by google said that rt's
german channel had received a strike so
a warning over material that it had
uploaded which breached youtube
standards on covet 19 misinformation
rt's german channel was subsequently
suspended from uploading new videos
to its channel for a week then what
happened was that youtube said that rt's
german channel try to quote circumvent
the restriction by uploading videos onto
another channel that it has
which is their feel and apart now as a
result both channels were terminated for
breaking youtube's terms of service now
this story could sound similar in some
ways to what happened in august when sky
news australia was banned from posting
um new videos and live streaming on its
youtube channel
for a week after violating um the
platform's policies over covert 19
misinformation and information with
regards to the pandemic so what sort of
content are we talking about here well
this is what's still a little bit
unclear now youtube didn't disclose
which videos exactly but the
editor-in-chief of rt said that it was
related to interviews with critics of
covet 19 measures
but there were also reportedly clips
discussing potentially risky or unproven
covet 19
treatments we'll say um
youtube then said and quote doesn't
allow content about covert 19 that poses
a serious risk of harm it also says that
it doesn't allow content that spreads
medical misinformation that contradicts
local health authorities and also world
health uh organized the world health
organizations medical information about
covert 19. so we can sort of gather a
little bit from all that information
what type of videos we're talking about
yeah i mean perhaps better late than
never there pablo thank you very much
all right let's look at the politics
said to be behind this move with our
political correspondent simon young he's
following that side of the story good
evening to you simon
rt says this youtube band is politically
motivated and that germany is behind it
their editor-in-chief even accused the
german government of declaring a media
war
have they produced any evidence
brent i'm not sure there is any concrete
evidence of these claims but the head of
rt in germany said that her organization
had done nothing wrong and that they
were being represented as having
broken the rules but that's that's a
false representation and in moscow the
russian foreign ministry called it an
unparalleled act of media aggression
and suggested that the german government
might somehow be behind it well of
course youtubers we've heard says that
this is about uh coveted misinformation
and the german government for its part
uh has clearly rejected the idea that
it's got anything to do with this let's
uh listen to what the german government
spokesman said just earlier on
we have taken note of this decision from
youtube
and since there are different stories
about this on russian channels i want to
say very clearly this is a decision by
youtube federal government or
representatives of the federal
government have nothing to do with this
decision
anyone who claims that is constructing a
conspiracy theory it's a decision by
youtube youtube has justified it we take
note of that
so simon is this part of the continuing
souring of relations between moscow and
berlin or do you think there's something
more substantial at work here
well that's hard to say but uh certainly
relations between moscow and berlin uh
there's some tension in that
relationship and this uh war of words is
likely to make it a little tenser if
anything
uh the kremlin has been saying that you
know it appears as if some russian laws
may have been broken and there have been
calls uh reports anyway of calls from uh
authorities there
for
retaliatory action uh that is to say
potentially uh banning or some kind of
reprisals against uh
youtube or perhaps against german media
operating in russia
the german government spokesman again
today said well there is no basis for
any such retaliation and indeed any talk
of it shows uh that such people who talk
about that have a poor relationship as
he put it with press freedom all right
our political correspondent simon young
on the story tonight here in berlin
simon thank you